Okay, so let's look at the solution for
this part of the quiz. Do we dispatch an instruction in cycle five?
No we do not. All of these instructions are waiting for
something to be broadcast. So until we actually broadcast some results, and
these instructions can capture the values, they will not be able to dispatch.
Both of them are waiting for something. So this should be empty.
Do we write any results? Yes. The instruction in ROB3 is an add.
It began executing in cycle four. It takes one cycle to execute. So
in cycle five it will write its result. So the correct answer here is ROB3.
This is which instruction writes its result in cycle five.
As a result of this right result. In cycle five, we mark this
ROB3 entry as done. The value of three is broadcast with the tag of ROB3.
It gets captured here because this instruction is waiting for ROB3. So in fact,
because we can dispatch this instruction in the same cycle, in cycle five.
This subtract does dispatch. So the instruction in ROB5 will dispatch,
and it will begin executing in cycle six. So this is somewhat of a trick
question because you needed to first figure out that this write result happens,
and as a result of this we enabled the dispatch of this instruction. So
it's kind of interesting in that in this cycle this instruction has been issued.
Captured a result and dispatched.